there's an interesting
person i'd like to bring up just as an
example
uh bill gates yeah
so he gets a very large amount of hate
on the internet yeah and there's
something about him this is me talking
that you that he seems out of touch
about that hate
he i i believe at least in my
understanding that uh with with the
resources he has
he's trying and is actually doing a lot
of good
and yet there's a gigantic amount of
hate conspiracy theories and stuff like
that right and it feels like that's the
case
because he's somehow out of touch
with with people so i wonder how you
stay in touch
with the voice of the people without
being destroyed
by the outrage is there is there any
wisdom you have to that or
i don't know about wisdom but i've
thought about this too because
yeah you want to always be open to
feedback especially from people who have
like your best interests at heart right
and if you can become
isolated from it and just like you know
surrounded by yes people and um i mean
who knows maybe maybe like
she and putin and people like that are
in situations i have no idea
um
but if you listen to too much of it and
you just try to please everyone you'll
never get anything done and i mean most
of the best leaders are people
who
they can act when they believe that they
they're doing something net positive for
the world and humanity and they actually
don't really care if they piss off some
proportion of the people
almost anything you're going to do of
significance in the world today is going
to piss off five percent of people maybe
maybe 49 of people or whatever maybe 60
i don't know
so
you never want to become so surrounded
by people who just work for you and will
say yes and then you think like well i'm
a genius and i'm like i'm a that's how
you become a dictator or whatever
um but you also can't care so much about
what people think because then you'll
never do anything that's truly authentic
to yourself
one other thought on that by the way i
think it's a really good question
so i've thought about this a lot like
why
you know people generally kind of hate
on zuck and they hate on
bill gates and they hate on um
they don't really hate on elon actually
elon has a lot of haters too but it's a
different thing this is measured this is
measured i was looking at some surveys
so i think
uh zuck is the most so loved and hated
right yeah uh zuckerberg is the most
both uh loved and hated he's the most
hated and then i think it's bill gates
and elon is down there i think it's like
uh 40 percent hey zuck people asked and
then elon is in the double digits but
low double digits and so it's
interesting you just look at this day
ask yourself why right so i ask myself
this sometimes too because
i don't claim to know any of these
people well but like i've i've met them
briefly and i my impression is that
they're actually all smart people trying
to do good things in the world so
there's not too much difference there
despite public perception perception so
why is it that summer really hated some
aren't i mean
it's a complicated question um obviously
since you know zuck and his facebook got
blamed for the whole election thing and
all that didn't help um social media has
gotten a lot of pressure just from like
you know hey why aren't you solving all
of society's tough problems it's like
well they're just one company but one
thing i've noticed is that
you know a lot of these people they're a
little they have like asperger's right a
little bit and um sometimes you know
people with aspergers don't really emote
in the same way and so i think it's
almost a form of like um
um
like
bias against um
their cognitive
type or something which is like that
person doesn't emote right i don't trust
their in their intentions
and um
the other thing i've thought about too
is that sometimes i think some leaders
you know um like maybe zuck or bill
gates they can come across as like a
little bit
pr rehearsed like they're basically um
they're giving the pr approved answers
as where elon just says whatever he
thinks like to a fault so even if people
hate what he says or like at least i
believe it's authentic
so i've always thought about that too
for myself i'm like how do i because you
can you can [ __ ] it up on both sides
right like if you just come out and
you're like saying whatever
stream of consciousness
you'll often end up like pissing off
people on your team or like saying
tripping over some like regulation that
you you know
um there's all kinds of things about
running a public company you know you
can't say certain stuff
but if you're too pr approved and your
answer is like nobody trusts you what
you're saying and so anyway this is
something i think about a lot i don't
think i have the right answer but i'm
trying to i'm trying to find that one
and more and more with the internet
there's a premium on authenticity just
like you're saying yeah people really
really appreciate that so for leaders
it's a challenge to be how do i uh make
sure i'm authentic but also
um don't say stupid [ __ ] yeah and so
that's an interesting thing i've noticed
that um just having interacted with the
with a bunch of leaders
that
you have to be careful how much you
surround yourself with pr folks
because the best i would say let me just
say a nice thing about marketing and pr
folks the best
marketing folks are extremely good yeah
so they understand
exactly what great marketing is and get
great pr it's authenticity it's showing
revealing the beauty as opposed to uh pr
and marketing out of fear oh don't say
that don't say this don't that
because then you you start living in
this kind of that pushes you towards a
bubble where you can't express the we
your your beautiful quirks and weirdness
and all that kind of stuff and also
the cool the beautiful things about what
you're doing i find like um especially
with the tech thing like even like
coinbase
the way to reveal the beauty of it
is not only by showing all the things
you could do with it but showing that
there's great engineering going on
underneath so letting the nerds shine
too it doesn't have to be like
uh
these kind of commercials where it's
like uh
a happy family using uh coinbase to send
a transaction about uh flowers for mom
or something like that like it could be
also like gritty stuff and real stuff
you